كانه ما يداني مرفوعتان الى السماء
ضلعتان حامدتان شاكرتان
الانعام والالاء في قطر تكتب قصيدتها ليس
على الورق بل على الارض عمران ونماء ما
كان ذلك صدفه فالصفه لا تصنع وطنه بل هي
خطه طموحه خرجت من السطور اذ كانت حلما في
مصطلح على تسميته رؤيه قطر 2030
فاذا رايت ثم رايت حداثه في ترتيب الحياه
وصناعه الجمال وتطورا ياخذ بكل منشط مما
راشدها فتلك هي تجليات الرؤيا الرؤيه التي
حرصت على تحقيق اعلى درجات الحدث دون ان
تغفل عن الامساك بيد التقاليد والتراث
فلا ينتظم طارف عن ثالث
فاذا رايت ثم رايت تطورا في جميع اوجه
الحياه ما خلا منها وجه فانما هي الخطه
تخرجها من الورق اراده جعلت شعارها قطر
تستحق الافضل اما الهدف الذي نصت عليه
الخطه التي صدرت بموجب قرار اميري في
العام 2008 فهو تحقيق التقدم والازدهار
بحيث تتحول قطر الى دوله متقدمه قادره على
تحقيق التنميه المستدامه التي تؤمن العيش
الكريمه لشعبها جيلا بعد جيل
الصدفه لا تستطيع وطنه
اعلان فوز قطر في عام 2010 بتنظيم كاس
العالم للعام 22
كان استراحا لفعل يقع خارج المتخيل خارج
المتوقع فقد اخلد الدول العالم غير
المتنفذه الى المقاعد التي خصصها لها ما
يسمى العالم الاول
كانت الدفع بملف قطر اصاله عن نفسها
ونيابه عن منطقه العربيه وما وراء المنطقه
العربيه فعلا سر به خلق واغاظ من اغاض
سيؤثر ظفر قطر بتنظيم كاس العالم لكره
القدم البطوله التي ينشد الى متابعه
فعالياتها الاف الملايين من البشر في
مختلف ارجاء الارض
سيمثل دفعا قويا لخطه التنميه الطموحه
سيتحول التحدي امام قطر الى ملحمه وطنيه
كبرى حتى لا تبدو في سنواتها العشر
الاخيره البقعه الاكثر نشاطا وتشيدا على
مستوى العالم اليوم صار ما كان مستحيلا
ممكنه
الاجماع من لدن الفيفا الى اخر مشجع بكره
القدم على ان بطوله قطر ستكون الاكثر
تميزا من بين جميع بطولات كاس العالم
فكل شيء يتصل بالبطوله تم اعداده ليس فقط
ليخدم وظيفته وغرضه بل يجب ان يكون ايه في
الجمال
الملاعب التي اعدت المباريات مثل التحف
المعماريه وقيما انسانيه ووفاء للتراث
ولثقافه المكان وقد تمثل تجريبا معماريا
فانتازيا مثل استاد تسعه سبعه اربعه الذي
صمم ونفذ بحاويات البضائع ليمثله رقم
الاتصال الدولي لقطر
ليست فقط كاس العالم بل هي جائزه كتارا
لروايه العربيه الجائزه الارفع في مجالها
وسيكتشف ان قطر ليست الغاز فقط بل هي
جائزه الشيخ حمد للترجمه والتفاهم الدولي
الاعلى قيمه في مجال ترجمه عيون المعارف
الانسانيه العالميه الى العربيه
سيكتشفون القادم الى قطر ان مؤسسه قطر
التعليميه تحتضن افضل الجامعات الغربيه
بجانب الجامعات الوطنيه وان المكتبه
الوطنيه هي الاحدث بين المكتبات والاضخم
عدد كتب في منطقه العربيه
كاس العالم سيجلي قطر للناس سواء
بالمشاهده عيانا او بالمتابعه عبر شاشات
التلفزيون على مدى نحو شهر والذين يشاهدون
في مختلف انحاء العالم ستقول عينهم بي ان
سبورت الشبكه الرياضيه الاكبر في دول جنوب
الكره الارضيه
كثير مما صنعت قطر في مشروع تاسيس الدوله
الحديثه مظهرا ومخبرا ما كان ليظهر بهذا
الجلاء لولا كاس العالم
وهو بمثابه الجائزه الكبرى
لمشروعي رؤيه قطر
اما اذا تاملت فيما وراء ايات كره القدم
فستجد كثيرا من الحذر الكلامي والثقافي
والاجتماعي الذي من شانه مركزيه سياسيه
وثقافيه وقياميه لا تكاد ترى في الخصوصيات
الثقافيه للمجتمعات الاخرى الا مفارقه
لسويتها الاخلاقيه
ولسدادها المؤبد قصتك كاس العالم في قطر
تفتح باب لطال ما ظل مغلقه وهو ان العالم
اوسع من يحشر سكانه في قالب قيمي ثقافي
واحد وان فكره الهوامش المغبونه والمدرسه
سوقا استهلاكيه والمسجوله في خانه
المشاهده هي مما يزكي حجاج المحاجين
بضروره تعدد اخطاب العالم
بطوله كاس العالم في قطر خطوه واسعه في
ذلك الطريق اما الذين اساءهم تنظيم قطر
كاس العالم
واطلقوا عليها حملات التشكيك والتشويه
فلعل الدوله المضيفه
تتعذى بقول نبيل عربي قديم فان اكلوا لحمه
وفرت لحومهم وان هدموا مجدي بنيت لهم مجده
[تصفيق]